[موسيقى]
صواريخ فتون تخترق الحدود الرومانيه
والنيت يتاهب امام الملاك الغاليه تعلن
امدادك
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تجلس كان هل حان وقت
الانسحاب واخيرا هولندا تحضر طائراتها
للدخول في الحرب الاوكرانيه واكثر من عشره
الاف جندي اوكراني يعلنون الاستسلام ما
الذي يجري مستودعات الذخيره الاوكرانيه في
مهب الريح موسكو تجدد القصف بكثافه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فيما يبحث عن حلفاء
الجدد وسويسرا للاوكرانيين لان الخريطه في
حربكم ابدا وبسبب رئيس مجلس النواب الكندي
يقدم استقالته بعد انسحاب فرنسا من النيجر
الولايات المتحده تهرع الى افريقيا
المصائب لا تاتي فرادى والعراق تحل به
الفاجعات امريكا تستفز الصين وتعلن ولاده
جديدين في الخريطه العالميه
رومانيا تستنشق بارود الحرب الحرب تخرج عن
نطاقها والمعارك تتسع مع الايام وما كان
يصيب الاوكران صار اليوم لدى جيرانهم ها
هو القصف الروسي على اوديسا يؤدي الى
تعليق خدمه العبارات بين رومانيا
واوكرانيا حيث قالت شرطه الحدود الرومانيه
في بيان لها ان حركه المرور عبر معبر
الدانوب بمقاطعه تركيا مغلقه بسبب الهجمات
الكثيفه في الجانب الاوكراني وقالت وسائل
اعلام محليه ان ضربات روسيه تتسبب في
اغلاق معبر حدودي بين اوكرانيا ورومانيا
ولا ندري هل تتوقف الحرب عند الحدود
الرومانيه ام انها ستغوص الى عمق رومانيا
الدوله العضو في النيتو تستمر الحرب
باستمرار صب الزيت على النار هنا فادت
وكاله انباء ان لجنه الدفاع في البلغاري
وفقط على خطه لارسال صواريخ اس 300 معطوبه
الى اوكرانيا وسيتم اصلاحها هناك وكاني
بالاوروبيين اصبحوا يرمون قمامه اسلحتهم
الى كييف على الاوكرانيين ان يتصرفوا هل
ستكون خرده الاسلحه هذه مجانيه يا ترى اما
في هولندا فاعلنت وزيره الدفاع الهولنديه
كاسا امستردام تعول على امداد قوتك
بمقاتلات اف 16 بحلول العام 2024 الموعد
يقترب وما هي الا اشهر قليله لنرى هل
سيصدق الهولنديون ام لا لكن هناك من يرفض
دعم اوكرانيا على الاطلاق حيث رفض المجلس
الوطني الغرفه الكبرى للبرلمان السويسري
مبادره لتشريع اعاده تصدير الاسلحه
للبلدان المنخرطه في صراعات عسكريه بما في
ذلك اوكرانيا وهو ما يعني ان سويسرا
تقولها
لا اسلحه لدينا نعطيها لكم حتى تنتهي
الحرب من جهتها ذكرت صحيفه
نقلا عن مصادر مطلعات ان السلطات
الالمانيه اجلت ارسال صواريخ تاورس بعيده
المدى للقوات الاوكرانيه بسبب المخاوف من
الانجرار الى مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا بدا
الخوف يتسلل الى قلوب احفاد هتلر وهذا
التراجع خير دليل ميدانيا اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني
جدد لامدادات الذخيره في وقت جددت فيه
روسيا قصفها على منطقه اوديسا بالتزامن مع
اندلاع اشتباكات على جبهات في شرق وجنوب
اوكرانيا في الاثمان نقلت وكاله الروسيه
انه حتى الان اكثر من عشره الاف جندي
اوكراني منذ منتصف الصيف اختاروا الحياه
واستخدموا التردد
149.200 لتسليم انفسهم للجيش الروسي ويتم
تقديم الطعام بشكل دوري يوميا لهؤلاء
الاسرى وهم يتلقون كل الرعايه الطبيه
اللازمه وها نحن نتصفح المصدر امامكم في
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه فيما قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش وجه الضربه
بصواريخ عاليه الدقه ضد 12 مستودعا
للاسلحه والذخيره تابعا للقوات الاوكرانيه
في منطقه كيسيلوفكا بمقاطعه خرسون ودمرت
كليا وهو ما ادى الى تدمير اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف طمن من الذخيره والعهده على المصدر
الموضح امامكم قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها وجه الضربه بصواريخ عاليه الدقه
الى مستودعات للاسلحه والذخيره تابعه
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه كيس اليوفكا
بمقاطعه خرسون فقد ادت الضربه الصاروخيه
الى انفجارات ونشوب النيران في اثني عشر
مستودع ذخيره وتدميرها واشارت الوزاره في
بيانها الى ان هذه المستودعات كانت تحتوي
على اكثر من ثلاثه الاف طن من الذخيره
والقذائف من مختلف العيارات ليرد الرئيس
الاوكراني ان قوتي بلاده دمرت الخدمات
اللوجستيه ومقرات القوات الروسيه في شرق
وجنوب البلاد واضاف زرنسكي ان قوات بلاده
تتقدم في اتجاه دونيتسكي لتعلن روسيا
تعليق حركه السيارات على جسر القرم وهو
اجراء تتخذه غالبا بسبب هجمات اوكرانيه
وبالعوده الى خرسون على محاكم المقاطعه ان
السلطات الاوكرانيه بدات باجلاء سكان 31
مركزا اهليا في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
السلطات الاوكرانيه هناك ان يدبر الاوكران
لمكيده جديده ام انها بوادر الانسحاب
بالمقابل قناه الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه زبورغوتشا ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت 130 هجوما طال سبع وعشرين
بلده في المقاط خلال يوم واوضحتنا 116
قذيفه استهدفت بلدات عده منها
وقد الحق القصف دمارا في 15 مبنى سكنيا
بينما تظهر هنا حصيله الخسائر الاوكرانيه
خلال 24 ساعه حيث اظهرت بيانات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان الخسائر البشريه للجيش
الاوكراني بلغت نحو 715 عسكريا من جهه
اخرى لم تترك موسكو للاوكران اي مجال في
الصناعه العسكريه حيث صرح امين مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع في اوكرانيا
من انتاج الصواريخها الى خارج البلاد بعد
ان استهدفت القوات الروسيه موقعا لتجميعها
وسؤال هو ما هي الدوله او الدول التي
ستقبل بتصنيع الاسلحه للاوكران لتدور بنا
الاحداث الاوكرانيه وتضعن في كندا حيث قدم
رئيس مجلس العموم الك
استقالته وذلك بعد الجدل الذي اثاره تكريم
احد المحاربين القدامى الذين قتلوا مع
النازيين خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وذلك خلال زياره الرئيس
والتطورات في العراق العرس ينقلب الى باتم
وحزن دائم يا لقساوه الاقدار قاعه الافراح
تتحول الى رماد ليعم البكاء الاراضي
العراقيه وها هي وزاره الصحه العراقيه
توالن ارتفاع ضحايا حريق قاعه حفل زفاف
بمحافظه
نينوى الى اكثر من مئه وعشرين قتيلا
ومئتين مصاب وقال الدفاع المدني ان سبب
الحريق هو استخدام الالعاب الناريه اثناء
حفل الزفاف ما ادى الى اشتعال النيران
داخل القاعه ثم اتساع دائره الحريق من
جانبه اكد الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد
ضروره فتح تح ومعرفه ملابسات حادث الحريق
في قضاء الحمدانيه واتخاذ كافه اجراءات
السلامه لمنع تكرار هذه الفاجعه بعد
الاحداث الاخيره في افريقيا وطرد القوات
الفرنسيه تفقد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
المتمركزه في قاعده خليج ماندا في كينيا
بالقرب من الحدود مع الصومال وكانت
استقباله نظيره الكيني وعدد من القيادات
العسكريه الامريكيه والكينيه اعلنت امريكا
ولاده بلدين جديدين في خريطه العالم الامر
الذي استفز الصين اعترفت امريكا بجزيرتي
كوكو دولتين مستقلتين في المحيط الهندي
فيما اعتبر مراقبون خطوه الاعتراف هذه
بمثابه وضع حد للتقارب الصيني من
[موسيقى]